Transcriber: Bilge Yilmaz
Gözden geçirme: Sancak Gülgen
Merhaba.
En son konuşmacı olduğuma göre
istediğim kadar konuşabilirim herhalde.
Yorulmuşsunuzdur,
ufak ufak kaçsak diyorsunuzdur.
Baştan söyleleyim en güzel cümlemi
en sonda söyleyeceğim.
Ben bir beyin cerrahıyım.
Burası benim işyerim.
Dünyanın en zor işlerinden
birini yapıyorum.
Sizce benim işimin zor yanı nedir?
Saatlerce bu mikroskobun
altında çalışmak mı?
Yoksa yaptığım en küçük bir yanlış
hareketin bir insanın hayatına mal olması,
ölümüne yol açması ya da
sakatlığına yol açması mı?
İşimin en zor yanı bu değil.
Beyninde tümör olduğunu öğrenen yada
bir damar baloncuğunun patlamasıyla
beyin kanaması geçirip hayatı altüst olan
insanlarla karşılaşmak.
İşimin en zor yanı hastanedeki odamda
az önce çocuğunun beyinciğinde tümör
olduğunu öğrenen bir anneyle göz göze
gelmek, ona bu durumu anlatabilmek.
Ben hastalarıma bir olgu olarak bakmam.
Onları duygularıyla, düşünceleriyle,
sevdikleriyle, işleriyle bir bütün olarak
görürüm.
Onları yakalandıkları hastalığın nasıl
etkileyeceğini düşünürüm,
onlara nasıl yardım edebileceğimi.
Bugün size anlardan ve tercihlerden
söz edeceğim.
Momentum bana önce bir momenti,
yani bir anı hatırlatıyor.
Sonrada hareketi.
Hereketin en önemli özelliği yönü.
Bir kamyon otoyolda dümdüz
giderken sorun yoktur.
Ama direksiyonu kırıp bariyerlere
yönelirse sorun başladı demektir.
Hereketin yönü seçimi işaret eder,
tercihi işaret eder.
İnsanlar anlarıyla ve tercihleriyle
var olurlar.
Bir an nedir?
Bir dakika? On dakika?
Eğer 1 an 1 dakikaysa, uykuyu çıktıktan
sonra yaşam boyu geçireceğiniz
aşağı yukarı 25 milyon anınız olacaktır.
10 dakika ise 2,5 milyondan.
Ve bu tabiki bir yenidoğan için geçerli.
Yani pek fazla zamanımız var sayılmaz.
O zaman anlarımız ve tercihlerimiz
önem kazanıyor.
Size anlardan örnek vereceğim.
Tercihlerden, hastalarımdan,
kendimden , insanlardan.
17 yaşında bir delikanlı, bir sürü
sorunu var. Hangimizin yokki?
Üstüne üstlük birde aşık.
Sevgilisiyle konuşmak istiyor.
Takmış kafaya o gün mutlaka konuşacak.
Mesaj üstüne mesaj atıyor, cevap yok.
Telefonla arıyor, cevap yok.
Son bir kere daha arıyor, meşgule alıyor.
Gidiyor salonun penceresini açıp
bırakıyor kendini boşluğa.
Hayır ölmüyor.
Belden aşağısı felç kalıyor.
Bütün sorunları aynen devam ederken
kalan ömrünü
bir tekerlekli sandalyede geçirecek.
Hiçbir tercih yaşamın
karşısında olmamalı.
Kendi hayatımıza dair vereceğimiz
kararlar da böyle.
Çünkü bu dünyada tek bir kutsal şey var,
o da canlıların yaşamı.
Buna Afrikada açlıktan ölen, Ortadoğuda
bombalardan ölen çocukların yaşamıda
dahil.
Buna Faroe adalarında katledilen
yunusların,
belediyelerin zehirlediği
köpeklerin yaşamıda dahil.
Buna gezide avm yapmak için,
Validebağ'da cami,
Soma'da santral yapmak için
kesilen ağaçlarınkide.
Bu arada hanımlar beyler, eğer
sevgilileriniz size şiddet küfür içeren
mesajlar atmıyorlarsa bir zahmet
onları yanıtlayıverin.
Benim boyle kendini boşluğa bırakan
çok hastam oldu.
Bir başka hasta 29 yaşında bir kadın.
İyi bir evliliği var, mutlu bir
evliliği var, iyi bir işi var.
Başı ağrıyor. Bir MR çektiriyor.
Büyük bir damar yumağı tespit ediliyor.
Bana geldi.
Kendisine hastalığıyla ilgili
bilgi vermeye başladım.
Doğduğundan beri beyninde olduğunu ve
yaşamının sonuna kadar
zararsız bir şekilde orada kalabileceğini
söyledim.
Lafı ağzımdan aldı.
''Ama yarın kanayabilir ve ölebilirim de.''
dedi.
Uzun zamandır hastalar hastalıklarını
internetten çalışıp geliyorlar.
Hatta beni de çalışıyorlar.
Bana dair herşeyi biliyorlar.
''Siz bu ameliyatı iyi yapıyormuşsunuz''
dedi. ''Beni kurtarın.''
Ameliyatın risklerini anlattım.
Ölüm ve sakatlık vardı.
''Ameliyat olmak istiyorum.'' dedi.
20 saat sürdü ameliyatı.
Ve ameliyattan 2 bacağı ve 1 kolu
felçli olarak çıktı.
Sonra bana hayatımda bir hastamdan aldığım
en güzel hediyeyi verdi.
Bu kartpostal.
Üstünde eşinin ve kendisinin resmi var.
Arkasında şunlar yazıyor.
Ocak 2002 hastalığın teşhisi.
Nisan 2002 operasyon.
Ağustos 2002 Kaçkar'da 3200 metre.
Bir tercih yapmıştı ne mutlu bana ki
ona istediği hayatı verebilmiştim.
Ama bundan sonraki öykü biraz acıklı.
30'lu yaşlarının ortalarında bir erkek
hasta bir sara nöbeti geçiriyor.
Acile götürüyorlar. Film çekiliyor.
Beyninin sağ tarafında kocaman bir tümör.
Bana geldi. Yüzünde acı bir gülümsemeyle
''Hocam yaşarmıyım?'' dedi.
Kötü huylu bir tümördü. İkimizde
''Bunun için mücadele edeceğiz.'' dedik.
2 yıl içinde 3 defa ameliyat ettim.
Bir gün telefonla beni aradı.
''Hocam'' dedi.''Bu iki yılı iyi yaşadım.
Yapmak istediklerimi yaptım.
Fantazilerim vardı, gerçekleştirdim.
İki yıla 40-50 yıllık hayatı sığdırdım.''
1 hafta sonra da öldü.
Peki böyle mi olması gerekiyor?
Duvara tosladıktan sonra mı hayatımızın
değerini anlamalıyız?
Her sabah bir dikdörtgen prizmasından
çıkıp başka bir dikdörtgen prizmasına
biniyoruz ve işimizin olduğu bir diğer
dikdörtgen prizmasına gidiyoruz.
Yaşamlarımız bu şekilde geçip giderken
hayal gücümüz, yaratıcılığımız soluyor.
Hep nasıl daha çok para kazanırız,
nasıl daha yükseğe çıkarız,
nasıl daha güçlü oluruz diye uğraşıyoruz.
Peki güçlü olmak bizi daha iyi,
daha düzgün yapıyor mu?
Çoğu zaman daha kötü yapıyor.
Kendimize etrafımızdakilere ve üzerinde
yaşadığımız bu gezegene yabancılaşıyoruz.
En son ne zaman bir Dünya
Haritasına baktınız?
Kaçınız kutuplara gitmeyi,
okyanusların dibindeki çukurlara
bir denizaltı ile inmeyi hayal etti?
Peki sizler bunu hayal etmezseniz
çocuklarınız nasıl Jüpiter'e Uranüs'e
gitmeyi hayal edecek?
Bu topraklardan böyle çocuklar
nasıl çıkacak?
Size iki denizciden örnek vereceğim.
Ben de denizciyim.
İki büyük denizci kadından.
İlkinin adı Jean Socrates.
Emekli bir matematik öğretmeni,
70 yaşında bir kadın.
50'sinden sonra yelken yapmayı
öğrenmişler eşiyle.
Evlerini satıp bir yelkenli alıyorlar,
dünyayı dolaşacaklar.
''Nereida - Su perisi'' ismini veriyorlar.
Ama kocası kansere yakalanıp ölüyor.
Bu 70 yaşındaki kadın
zor bir işe kalkışıyor.
Tek başına en zor rotadan hiç durmadan
dünyayı dolaşmak.
Çok az kişi başarmış bunu.
Yola çıkıyor.
Yolculuğu tamamlıyor, ama yolda
durmak zorunda kalıyor.
Amacına ulaşamıyor.
Bir daha yola çıkıyor.
60 mil kala, bitirmesine şu kadarcık kala
tekrar durmak zorunda kalıyor.
Bir daha yola çıkıyor, dünyayı hiç
durmadan tek başına dolaşan
en yaşlı insan oluyor ve çok az
sayıda insandan biri.
Başka bir büyük denizci Ellen MacArthur.
Ama kendi küçük, 1.52 boyunda.
Dünyanın en zor spor müsabakalarından
biri kabul edilen
Vendée Globe yarışına katılıyor.
18 metrelik bir yelkenlide güney
okyanusunun 10-15 metreye varan
dalgalarıyla boğuşuyor 94 gün.
Ve bu yarışı ikinci olarak bitiriyor.
3 yıl sonra bir trimalanla dünyayı
yelkenle en hızlı dolaşan insan oluyor.
Şimdi bu iki kadında kansere karşı
kurdukları vakıflada
denizciliklerinin yanında mücadelelerine
devam ediyorlar
ve ülkelerinin çocuklarına
ilham oluyorlar.
1 yıl önceye dönüyorum.
Bir hastam beyin kanaması geçiriyor,
2 saat sonra ameliyathanede.
Bu video onun ameliyatından bir bölüm.
Birazdan başıma bir beyin cerrahının
başına gelebilecek en berbat şey gelecek
Erken ruptur ( yırtılma-yırtık)
diyoruz buna.
Daha hiçbir şeye hakim değilken,
hastanın anatomisine hakim değilken
anevrizma patlıyor.
Bir hortumdan fışkıran su gibi büyük
bir basınçla beynine gitmesi gereken kan
dışarıya akıyor.
Bu kanamayı birkaç dakika içinde
durduramazsam hastayı kaybedeceğim.
Saniyeler ilerliyor, benim de koroner
damarlarım büzüşmeye başlıyor.
Ama benim işim bu. Geçtiğimiz 25 yılda
yüzlerce yaptım ben bu ameliyatlardan.
Bu kanamayı nasıl durduracağımı biliyorum.
Bu anevrizmayı klipledim.
Hastayı kurtardım.
Ben işini çok seven bir beyin cerrahıyım.
İşini çok iyi yapan bir beyin cerrahıyım.
Çocukluk hayallerimin
mesleğini yapıyorum.
Bir sürü asistan yetiştirdim.
Öğrencler yetiştirdim.
Kitaplarım var, ulusal,
uluslararası düzeyde tanınıyorum.
Ama hayatımı tek bir alana sığdırmak,
yalnız beyin cerrahisi içinde kalmak
bana yetmemeye başladı.
Bu ameliyattan sonra çıktım Taksim'e
gittim, Haziran günleriydi.
Gezi direnişleri, içinde olan herkese
farklı ve yeni bir şey ilham etmiştir.
Bana da birçok şeyin yanında
adı dünya olan bir gezegende yaşadığımızı
düşündürdü.
2 ay sonra buradaydım.
Doğu Grönland, Angmagssalik Bölgesi,
Kulusuk isimli bir eskimo köyü.
Hedefim buradan yola çıkıp kanoyla
Kuzey Kutup Dairesini geçmekti.
Hayatımda hiç kanoya binmemiştim.
Hiç kürek çekmemiştim.
Tanımadığım insanlarla beraber
Grönland denizine açıldık.
Yüz kilometre ötedeki kuzey kutup
dairesine doğru kürek çekmeye başladık.
Çadırda kaldım Grönland
toprağının üstünde.
30 yıldır falan çadırda kalmamıştım.
Kutup ayısını kollayarak
açıkta tuvalete gittim.
8 gün boyunca yıkanmadım.
Yani modern kent yaşamına alışkın
50 yaşında bir tıp profesörü için
pek de olağan olmayan günler geçirdim.
Ama sonunda Kuzey Kutup Dairesini
kanoyla geçebildim.
3 ay sonrada buradaydım. Antarktika'da.
Ushuaia'dan,
O zaman başka yerlere de gideyim
alkış alacaksam.
Ushuaia'dan, yani dünyanın en güneyindeki
şehirden bu yelkenliye bindik
ve Drake Pasajına açıldık.
8 kişiyle beraber.
Hiç tanımadığım insanlarla.
Drake Pasajı dünyanın
en zorlu denizlerinden biri.
Güney amerikayla antarktika arasında.
Yılın 300 günü fırtınalı.
Drake Pasajını geçtiğiniz zaman
bu olağanüstü yere geliyorsunuz.
Antarktika'ya.
Farklı bir gezegene gelmiş
gibi oluyorsunuz.
Antarktika'nın en güzel yanı
hiç kimseye ait olmaması.
Hiçbir devlete hiçbir çokuluslu şirkete
ait toprağı yok.
Kimse doğal kaynaklarını
yağmalamaya çalışmıyor.
Antarktika yalnızca orada yaşayan
canlılara ait.
1 ay kaldım Antarktika'da.
Dönerken penguenlerle vedalaştım.
Penguenlerle vedalaşırken sordum tabi.
Çocuklar dedim neydi o gezi günlerinde
bütün kanallarda sizin belgeselleriniz
gösteriliyordu?
Penguenlerin cevabını aynen
size aktarıyorum.
Abi dediler biz Antarktika'da
yaşayan canlılarız, Taksim'e yapılacak
alışveriş merkeziyle hiç işimiz olmaz.
Gizli kamerayla çekmişler, fikrimizi
sormadan orada burada gösteriyorlar. Ne
çocukların yumurtadan çıkması kaldı,
ne cinsel hayatlarımız kaldı. Gördüğün
gibi biz anadan doğma siyah beyaz
yaratıklarız. Bizde İstanbul'da olsak Çarşı
Grubuyla beraber geziye çıkardık dediler.
Hoş bir manzara olurdu doğrusu.
Gümüşsuyu'nda büyük bir penguen
sürüsüyle beraber sloganlar atarak
geziye tırmanmak.
Dönüş yolunda Antarktika'dan dönüş
yolunda başıma
hayatımdaki en güzel şeylerden biri geldi.
Önce fıskiyelerini gördük.
Büyük bir kambur balina sürüsüydü.
Yelkenleri indirdik, bekledik.
Birer ikişer yanımıza geldiler birazdan
bütün teknenin etrafını
yirmi yirmibeş tane kambur balina kapladı.
Korkutucu gibi geliyor ama sanki
kum havuzundaki çocuklar gibiydiler
bizle oynamaya başladılar.
Okyanusun ortasında teknenin bir yanından
girip öbür yanından çıktılar.
Kuyruk gösterdiler, taklalar attılar,
fıskıyelerini yüzümüze fışkırttılar.
Bir evcil hayvan bile eve gelen
yabancıyı yadırgar.
Bu balinalar okyanusun ortasında bize
canlıların kardeşliği dersini verdiler.
Sonra ameliyathaneme geri döndüm.
Eskisinden daha büyük şevkle yapıyorum
ameliyatlarımı. Hastalarıma bakıyorum.
Ama ben aynı ben değilim.
Antarktika'nın, Grönland'ın sularında
dolaşmış biri aynı insan olmuyor.
İşimi yaparken ne zaman Güney Kutbuna
yürüyerek gideceğim, ne zaman Tongo'da
balinalarla yüzeceğim diye düşünüyorum.
Bu işler tehlikeli değil mi diyeceksiniz.
Tehlikeli.
Ama inanın bana kent yaşamı
daha az tehlikeli değil.
Hele türkiyede yaşıyorsanız
Antarktika kesinlikle daha güvenli.
Bir tane hayatınız var.
Tek bir tane.
Sonrasını bilmiyoruz.
Ama bu hayata doğduk ve bu hayatı
yaşayacağız.
Hayatınızı değiştirin.
Hemen yarın hayatınızı
değiştirmeye başlayin.
Hayal kurun.
Büyük ve imkansız şeyler hayal edin.
En zor olanı hayal edin.
Everest'e tırmanmayı düşünün, planlayın.
Belki günün birinde Ağrı Dağı'na
çıkarsınız. Az şey mi?
Bir yelkenliyle Akdeniz'de dolaşmayı,
okyanuslara açılmayı hayal edin.
Belki bir balıkçı motoru edinirsiniz,
İstanbul'u denizden yaşamaya başlarsınız.
Az şey mi?
Yarın hayatınıza dokunun.
Oturduğunuz seyirci koltuğundan çıkın,
sahneye gelin.
Kendi hayatınızın izleyicisi değil
oyuncusu olun.
Hayatınızın senaristi, yönetmeni olun.
Dokunun hayatınıza.
Bir kişi değişirse herkes değişir.
İnsanlar anlarıyla ve tercihleriyle
var olurlar.
Tercihlerinizi hayallerinizden
yana kullanın.
Unutmayın, Lapon denizcileri
hatırlayın her zaman.
Lapon denizciler kırmızı gözlü
geyiklerinin ardından açıldıkları
açıldıkları Kuzey Buz Denizinden
geri dönmemişlerdi.
Bir an bile geri dönmeyi düşünmemişlerdi.